well price matters we see that today
consumers are buying and they're not
buying the trend is away from the big
trucks and big SUVs towards smaller cars
price matters because it is the only
thing that is going to lead us away from
using fossil fuels until to something
else we're only going to switch away
from the fuels we're using now when we
find something that's cleaner cheaper
more convenient faster etc or all of the
above right we're not going to quit
using fossil fuels just because we
decide oh well I want to run my car on
broccoli or whatever it doesn't work
that way we have to have an alternative
that is workable so I think the price
the higher prices while painful are
maybe part of the transition to
something else and what is that
something else I can't say but we
clearly see a whole lot of money going
into alternative energy now look google
is investing in the solar business the
best performing stock in 2007 according
to Wall Street Journal was first solar
incorporated up eight hundred percent
last year so price matters investors
think that's the to bet on solar and
they may be right they could be wrong
but the point is we're not going to quit
using what we're using now I think for
for decades to come because it's taken
us a century or more to get where we are
so at the transition away from oil and
other fossil fuels is going to be a
protracted transition because we have so
much infrastructure already in place to
use what we have
well I think so one of the things that I
think would be a smart move is to
encourage more use of natural gas
particularly in terms of natural gas
fueled vehicles natural gas fueled
vehicles are they met less greenhouse
gases then then do gasoline or diesel
vehicles they emit virtually no air
pollutants and they are on a BTU basis
their fuel is about a third cheaper than
gasoline so that's a positive thing I
think that government could do by
providing incentives but clearly that
hasn't happened and and at one of the
amazing things is that today Brazil
which everyone talks about ethanol and
Brazil well at Brazil has ten times as
many natural gas vehicles as the u.s.
even though the US has more than ten
times as many motor vehicles as Brazil
so yes government could be providing
incentives if it wants to reduce oil
consumption but instead it's providing
mandates and the ethanol mandate being
clearly one of the most pernicious of
the mandates that are now in place